So our first Diamond Play Button
got a little bit broken.
So in this video,
we are going to try
to melt it down,
turn it into a trophy.
[Music]
You may have followed
some of our adventures
with our Diamond Play Button.
It had some issues.
We made a mold of it,
and that worked pretty well.
Then cleaning it up.
The diamond part in the middle
just kind of comes out,
and then one of Grant's children
might have dropped
it a little bit,
and so it broke there,
and I nicked it a little bit
while we were trying
to make the mold,
and so the surface got
a little messed up,
and overall, this thing
has had a stressful life,
even as short as it's been.
So we think that we're going
to do something else with it.
You can, see this is,
you know, it's got
our name on it.
The King of Random.
Congratulations on passing
10 million subscribers.
From YouTube.
It's all very nice and official.
I saw a video
where the Backyard Scientist
had a whole pool full of Orbeez,
and he poured some molten
aluminum into it,
and what came out
looked really awesome.
So I was thinking we want
to try and do that.
So here's the basic idea.
We're pretty sure
that it is mainly made
out of aluminum.
So we're going to try to melt
it down in our furnace,
and then pour it
into a bucket of Orbeez
to make a really cool shape.
It fits directly in,
but then, there would be
nothing to contain it.
Yeah.
And if it melted,
it would just all puddle
at the bottom of our furnace,
and that's no good.
So we've got
a stainless steel pot.
We're just going to set
this right on top,
and hope that all
of that propane power
will get up into the button,
and melt it down.
And this is some form of glass.
We're just going
to put all of it in,
and see what happens to it.
[Music]
Bye Diamond Play Button.
To try and keep some
of the heat in,
we are going to put another
metal bucket up on top of it.
Hopefully, that'll make
things go a little bit faster,
because this is
a large block of metal,
and we'll just check in
on it every 10 minutes or so.
[Music]
Haha!
Yeah.
You're going down button.
Down.
Hey, that's still hard.
I can like poke a hole in it.
But I can scrape this off.
There still some solid
in the middle there.
Yeah. Yeah.
Let's see if we can--
[inaudible] through.
[inaudible] Diamond button.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] something, little buddy.
[Music]
That is a lot
of liquid aluminum.
[Music]
All right.
First, a tiny tiny bit
to see if it's going to like
splash or anything.
[Music]
>> No.
>> That's awesome.
Okay.
Keep going.
[Music]
Now, that's a lot of steam.
Oh, I think we've melted
through the side of the bucket.
Orbeez are escaping.
We lost everything.
No, we haven't.
Much of it is still in there.
Keep going.
You can still make something
really cool out of this.
This side is not melted yet.
Keep--
Oh, our poor $3 bucket.
And so many Orbeez.
Oh!
Wow.
But that's already doing
>> something really good.
>> Okay, I gotta say,
I actually did see
that coming, kind of.
That's why our white bucket
is sitting in another bucket.
The other bucket
is full of sand.
I more suspected
the problem would be
that the aluminum would go down
to the bottom and melt through,
but it reached the side,
and unsurprisingly,
destroyed the side
of the bucket,
and just poured play button
all over the ground.
Oh man, the second bucket
has also started melting,
because the aluminum
did pour out onto the sand,
and it's just pressing
right there now.
This is really cool.
So you can actually
see over on this side,
the Orbeez caught,
and I can't tell if this is
aluminum and plastic, both?
But they're still there.
So once we,
once we're able to actually
get the Orbeez out of this,
and clean it all up,
we're going to have
something really weird.
I'm kind of feeling
like I'm just standing
in a steam shower right now.
It's incredibly hot still.
Look at this.
Look at this pattern
you got happening.
This looks like something alien.
Well, here's one part.
You went too far.
There's a hole
in the bottom too.
What did you do?
There's our glass button,
or a diamond,
I should say.
There's the glass,
and the triangle piece of steel.
It's not hot, it's just pointy.
Yes.
Look at that.
That's just pretty.
[Music]
Oh my gosh, just a bath
full of warm Orbeez.
That would be an experience.
That's something you
should have at a spa.
[Music]
Ah.
Got it?
Yeah.
[Music]
What?
This is amazing.
Yeah.
[Music]
This has slice up my gloves.
Alright, YouTube.
This is where you
should be giving out,
instead of Diamond Play Buttons.
This is cooler.
Oh, yeah. I want all the
Orbeez to stay forever,
but I know they won't.
That looks awesome.
[Music]
Guys, over the years, Grant
has accumulated some stuff.
He has quite a bit
of it collected by now,
and some of it,
he has had long enough,
and wants to get rid of it.
This isn't old used stuff
that he doesn't want anymore,
because it's old and used.
Its new stuff.
It's still in great condition.
So, today is our first giveaway
that we are actually
going to be using
the codes in the videos for.
You've probably seen them ever
since we had our Captain
America shield video.
We've started embedding
codes around the videos.
Sometimes, they pop up
with letters or numbers.
Sometimes, the King of Random
Shield logo pops up
for like one or two frames.
Sometimes, Grant pops up,
and he'll salute,
or he'll wave,
or any number of things.
And we're going to be using
those embedded codes to give
stuff away to you guys.
That's right.
And today is the first time,
and so here is the first thing
we're giving away.
We've got some of these,
they're called Mighty Mugs.
And here's the thing.
When I saw it in the box,
I thought, well
this look silly.
Who cares about that?
It's just got this picture
of a person,
like tipping it
and it doesn't tip.
Kinda thought it was just
gonna be like, I don't know,
a heavy weight at the bottom,
and I thought well,
that's really inconvenient.
But then, I actually opened it,
and started using it.
This thing is like,
I'm super amused with this.
This is actually really cool.
There's a suction cup
at the bottom.
So if you have any sort
of smooth surface,
and this isn't even
like a perfectly smooth table,
but it's pretty smooth.
It's like the suction
cup has a seal on it.
So that if you lift
it straight up,
it breaks the seal,
and you can just
pick up your cup.
Like you don't
feel any resistance.
It feels just like picking
up any other thermos.
But this, like the clever thing
is that if you don't pick it straight up,
if you go at it at an angle,
the suction cup seal catches
and it doesn't tip.
So we've got a couple
of these small ones,
we've one of these
taller ones here.
Both of them.
They don't fall over.
If you, I mean,
you can overcome it.
If you like push hard,
you can get it off,
push him sideways,
but it's not going
to fall over by accident.
You can, you know,
hit one cup
with the other cup.
They're crazy.
I might have to end up
getting one of these myself.
So here's what you have
to do to enter.
Okay, there's a link
in the description down below.
That's where you're going
to enter your code,
and to find that code,
you need to go watch our video
where we blended up
glow sticks in a blender.
For this video,
we're not using the the
appearing King of Random logo,
and we're not using
the appearing Grant.
We might use it
at a different contest giveaway,
sort of thing.
But for this time,
just the codes.
There should be five of them
hidden throughout the video.
So glow sticks in a blender,
and go check that out.
Come back here.
Link in the description.
Enter the code,
and you could win.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribed
to our channel,
and that way, you'll
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.